you're looking for exceptions rather  than the rule like you're looking for  the exception most people are fat  because they eat too much  and don't exercise again you have to eat  and so you're right and so when I say  what I was talking about in that post  was leaving the whales so if a girl I  was talking about if you if a girl gets  a ring okay and then she's 120 and she  decides to gain 100 pounds to 220. I  said leave the whale because I'm sorry  you you made the choice to gain 100  pounds that's disrespectful to your  husband and you know you you can  disagree with calling her a whale but  like what else are you gonna call her  that's that's that's a big woman